كل الحكايات تنتهي مع اقفال صفحتها
الاخيره الا حكايا المونديال المثيره
ينتهي كاس العالم ولا تنتهي قصصه وتساؤلات
جماهيره حتى بعد ساعات من المباراه
النهائيه
لكن هدفها الثالث في مرمى فرنسا ما زال
يثير والجدل حتى اللحظه بين صحته من عدمها
تكسر تساؤلات حول شرعيه الهدف وقبلها
تساؤلات اخرى عن مصاري ما حدث في المنطقه
للاذهان هدف اليابان في مرمى المانيا
وحالات اخرى اثاره الجدل وبين كل ذلك يشهد
مونديال العرب تالق لافتا للعرب والقاره
الافريقيه عنوانه العريض المغرب في المربع
الذهبي لكاس العالم وبعيدا عن اجواء
اللعبه واكثر قربه من فعالياتها المبهجه
كان الجماهير فاكهه الحدث الكبير وكانت
الملاعب ما كانت تالقها هذه الملاعب التي
تختلف مصائلها بعد نهايه كاس العالم قطر
عشرين اثنين وعشرين
وقبيله كاس العالم وضعت قطر خطه لاجل
الملاعب المونديال التي تختلف مصائرها بعد
نهايه البطوله التاريخيه لمونديال 20 22
ستادلوسيال الاكبر في البطوله ستعمل قطر
على تحويله لمجمع فيه العديد من المدارس
والمساكن والمحل والعيادات الطبيه مع
تحويل مرافقه لخدمه مدينه لوسيل الجديده
مع الحفاظ على شكله الخارجي
استاد المدينه التعليميه سيتم تقليس ساعته
الى 20,000 مقعد ويبقى كمركز رياضي
للمنتخب الوطني القطري للسيدات
استعادهما والجنوب على وضعيهما مع تقليص
مقاعده بين مصر اين نحو 20,000 مقعد فقط
لكل الملعب استاذ احمد بن علي سيتحول لمقر
لنادي الريان القطري وتخلص من قاعده الى
20 الف مقعد مع منح المقاعد المفككه
لمشاريع تطوير كره القدم حول العالم استاد
البيت او الخيمه يتم تفكيك الجزء العلوي
من هو تقليل عدد مقاعد الا 32,000 مقعد
والتبرع بالمقاعد المفكره استاذ خليفه
الدولي سيبقى على هذه كمقر لاكاديميه
ومجمع الالعاب المائيه مقر لمش- مشفى للطب
الرياضي اما الساعه 974 هو المصنوع من
حاويات قابله لتفكيك سيتم تفكيكه بالكامل
والتبرع به لاحدى الدول الناميه لدعم
رياضه
الوصله المنتخب الارجنتيني الفائز في كاس
العالم والعالم يترقب من هناك
الارجنتينيون يترقبون وصول المنتخب
الارجنتيني
لاكمال الاحتفالات بعد فوزها وحصولهم على
نجمه ثالثه في مونديال
كاس العالم 20 22 هم بانتظار خروج
اللاعبين في العاصمه
اكيد نشير بان
ممتاز كان شاهد مباراه الارجنتين في من
بيته ومن منزله وكتب تغريده على ذلك انا
اتابع المباراه من منزلي خلافا لما حصل في
مرات سابقه خصوصا في عام 1990 عندما لعبت
الارجنتين ضد الكاميرون وخسرت وقتها العرف
في الارجنتين الا يحضر رئيس الدوله
المباراه الفرق بين اللي حضر المباراه
النهائيه كان رئيس الفرنسي مانويل
بكاء الكبار اكيد نحن نقدر بانتظار ان يصل
المنتخب الارجنتيني في حال وصل معكم هذه
الصور مباشره في صباح العربيه
كاس العالم بعد طول
صباح العربيه دائما كان معنا في هذه في
هذا المونديال وهذه البطوله نايف ثقيل
نايف اهلا بك يعطيك الف عافيه كنت معانا
الطوال هذه التغطيه التغطيه الموندالاشي
22 كيف تبدو الاجواء بعد نهايه الموسم
اكثر في اليوم الاول من المونديال هناك
يعني ما يخص مغادره الجماعي
بعد المباراه مباشره شخصيا كانوا يحملون
حقائبهم من الملعب الى المطار وهناك
جماهير همم فضل الله في البقاء ويعني هذه
الجماهير نوعا ما هي الجماهير العائلات
يعني الذي الاب والام والاطفال في همم
الدوحه وقضاء جزء من الاجازه اجازه
الكريسماس وراس السنه وهناك يعني جماعي
وخصوصا جماهير البرازيل وايضا جزء من جميع
الارجنتين والدول البعيده همم يعني اقتلصت
البورصه للذهاب الى دبي تعليميه دبي يعني
احد المدن التي احلى من الكثير بزيارتها
وفي وصل منها فضله ان يختمه رحلتهم
الطويله او والجميله مع كاس العالم في همم
دبي بالامس كانت جميع المناطق التي شهدت
الاحتفالات وبالذات قبل الوسيله يعني قبل
الوسيله بالامس كانت شبه همم خالي هناك
فقط منطقتين كانت ممتلئه في همم الناس وهم
يعني سكان اهل قطر كانت منطقه كتامه
ومنطقه
كانوا يحتفلون باليوم الوطني همم فيما
فيما يخص ايضا ال- ال- المقتنيات او على
ماذا حدثت في الجماهير ان تقتني همم
كذكريات معها وهي مغادره طبعا بالاكل انه
همم
المنتجات التذكاريه لكاس العالم حيث قامت
يعني همم الجهات المسؤوله هنا بنقل جميع
النقاط البيع المنتجات الى مطار حمد همم
الدولي وعمل عليها صدري
اسمعك هل فعلا زاد ارتداء الناس للبشت بعد
ارتداء ميسي لا هو هل رايت ناسا بالفعل لا
يرتدون البشت في الشوارع
المنتجات بالفعل يعني تخيلي انه الجماهير
الارجنتين بعد المباراه
او في اليوم الثاني صباح امس اتجهت الى
سوق
يعنب المنتجات التراثيه يعني نفذت تقريبا
جميع جميع
الكلمه العاميه وبالجمع نفذت من سوق واقف
تم شرائها بالكامل من الجماهير الارجنتين
وقاموا في ارتداء ويبدا انه سيكون هذا عنف
بالنسبه لهم في كل الاحتفالات طبعا
بالتاكيد انه يعني جوده المنتج تختلف
كثيرا عن الذي
قبل تتويج بكاس العالم ولكن المفضلوا
وشاهدتهم بالامس همم
وهم يرتدون ال- ال- الخليجي في سوق واقف
وايضا في همم وهم سعيد ايضا بهذه من
الجوانب الايجابيه التي خلقتها او صناعتها
همم في خلال فتره همم
طيب نايف الملاعب نختم فيها الاستاذ يتحول
مجمع سكني ملعب 974 سيتم تبرع باحدثنا
اكثر عن الملاعب ومصيرها
دائما دعينا نتحدث عن ناصر الدعم اكبر او
ازمه تواجه الدوله المستضيفه لكاس العالم
هي ماذا ستفعل الملاعب نعلم ان جنوب
افريقيا الى الان تعاني بسبب التكلفه
الصيانه العاليه ملاعب البرازيل والتي
اقيمت في مدن همم ليست جماهيريه كبيره
تعتبر مهجوره الان ومبارياتها لا يحضرها
واقل من 500 مشجع لذلك تنبهت لهذا الامر
قبل ان تبني الملعب او تقوم بتصميمه وضعت
في حسبالها ماذا بعد المونديال كما ذكرتهم
عن التفاصيل همم الملاعب وكيف يتم همم
ولكن يعني تحتاج قطر الى ان تلتقاء
انفاسها بعد المونديال ستبدا في مشروع اخر
وهو همم الملاعب ما بعد همم نعلم ان اهم
احد اسباب نجاح ملف خطا في تنظيم كاس
العالم هو اا تبرعوها بمقاعد الملاعب
تقريبا 179,000 مقعد وهذا يعني فوق حاجتها
ول- اا الدول الناميه هذا سيساهم في تقليل
وتقليس تكاليف الصيانه ولكن خطا قطر لن
تفقد ميزتها في في الملاعب لانها ستستضيف
كاس اسيا همم المقبله ويكون يعني عام
الجذب لاي بطوله مستقبل في كل مرحله في
حياتنا يا نايف دائما في اشياء جديده
واجمل ما في المونديال ايضا اضيفه مهنيا
انه تعرفت عليه سعيد
وتقبلنا على الهواء مباشره في اكثر من
اللايف تحياتنا لك وان شاء الله بنتقابل
كمان
شكرا شكرا جزيلا شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
احنا وانت
لا لا اله الا الله
شرق وغرب عقل وقلبي بكل الفرحه ارحب
وا ارحب
[موسيقى]
عقله قلب ارحبوا هلا فيكم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
نعود معكم لهذه الصور المباشره من وينس
ايرس حيث بانتظار منتخب الارجنتين لوصولي
الى استكمال للاحتفالات بعد فوز في
مونديال قطر 20 22 هذه هي الحافله
بالانتظار طبعا من مدرج المطار والسجاد
الاحمر يفترش لاستقبال الابطال الابطال
مونديال قطر 2022 كل الاعين يا محمد على
وصول ميسي معانا في استديو الصحفي الرياضي
محمد حامد اهلا بك يا محمد كل الانظار
المتجه الى برنس خروج البطل ميسي ومعه
فريق الارجنتين الفائز ببطوله كاس العالم
صباح الخير مبروك
بس ما تنسى هاترك فرنسي ارجنتيني عدل
الموضوع المباراه كانت عاقله
فرنسا قدمت مستوى غير عادي للامانه وهو
افضل نهائي في تاريخ كاس العالم يعني من
الناحيه الفنيه ومن ناحيه الاثاره ومن
ناحيه السيناريو سيناريو خيالي لنهائي كاس
العالم
مساله الاحتفالات اليوم ستكون ستكون
احتفالات تاريخيه تحديدا في منطقه المسله
في بونس ايرث هم طول البطوله متواجدين في
هذا المكان يعني هو المكان اللي يعادل
الشانزليزي مثلا حينما الاحتفال الافتراضي
الذي لم يحدث في فرنسا
الذي لم يحدث في البرازيل ولكنه هذه المره
يحدث
تاريخ
استقبال في صور حتى الخالده لمونديال 2022
نبدا بالصوره الابراج اللي حازت الاهتمام
ميسي وعميل بس البث خلال الصوره
وتاريخها
تاريخيه تاريخيه بكل معنى الكلمه من
جانبين هو مبدئيا هي السعاده ممكن تكون
شيء مؤقت لكن المجد ابدي في لحظه سعاده
هنا لميسي وعشاق منتخب الارجنتين وعشاق
ميسي تحديدا ربما تكون المره الاولى في
تاريخ كره القدم كل العالم بتسمعي نفس
الكلمه انا مثلا مش الارجنتيني بس اتمنى
عشان ميسي فهي لحظه سعاده غير عاديه وهي
لحظه مجد للارجنتين ولميسي وداعين اقول
كمان جانب مهم لحظه مجد وتاريخ
لثقافه الخليج
صح هذه الصوره تحمل هذه الرمزيه حدثت
اختلافات يعني دعونا من فتح على كل الاراء
الاوروبيين انتقدوا ذلك
للان انا مش عارف ليه يعني انا احترم فكره
الانجليزيه في وقتها لا نعلم يعني سبب هذه
الانتقادات على اي حال هي لحظه تاريخيه
تجسد القوه الناعمه لمنطقه الخليج وثقافه
الخليج بكل معاني الكلب حكاياتنا معك
اليوم في صور وانت كان لك ايضا ان مصطلحات
حصريه من ضمن فريق صباح العربيه من خلال
ظهورك معنا طوال هذا الشهر في المونديال
اصبح الناس يتداولونها
لصباح العربيه يعني انا جزء منه لكن انا
بالنسبه لي انا سعيد ان يتم تداولها
وترددها من جانب كل الجماهير او من جانب
قطاع كبير دائما نقول تحديدا حينما قلت
اذا لم يتوج ميسي بكاس العالم تكون كره
القدم قد خانت نفسها ولم تخم من السيخ
وحينما قلت مبروك هنقول مبروك لكره القدم
وليس مبروك لمصر ومبروك لكاس العالم وليس
مبروك لميسي حينما يعتبر بكاس العالم طيب
خلينا نذهب للصوره ثانيه مباشره
لافراح اللاعبين على الابرز لحظه يعني
عشناها كعرب لحظه فرح سالم الدوسري في
مرمى الارجنتين ماذا تقول في ذلك
لحظه غير عاديه انا برايي كثره الحوادث
حتى امام المنتخب المغربي
وكانت ملهمه ان تفوز على المنتخب المرشح
الاول للبطوله فهذه اللحظه تاريخيه بكل
معنى الكلب فتحت الطريق امام المنتخبات
الاخرى وخاصه المنتخب المغربي وسيسجل
للسعوديه بالمناسبه انها من هزمت بطل
العالم
المانيا
اللقطه دي انا باحط لها عنوان ان
التكنولوجيا عن صفه اهلها يعني غالبا
التكنولوجيا قديمه من اليابان هي الكوره
الكوره بيتم التصوير من اعلى ربما الكره
نفسها لا تلامس ولكن من اعلى ظل الكره على
الخط جزء منها
كريستيانو المباراه
بالنسبه لرونالدو اسطوره لا احد يستطيع ان
يخفي انه اسطوره ولكن انا بقول له رساله
بسيطه شاريكك في رحله المجد نابع عنك او
كان نائب عنك في الحصول على كاس العالم
فلا تحزن
دائما اسمحي لي المنافسه ما بين طرفين
كبار بتعطي زخم لكل طرف
الكبار
اهتمام الناس خصوصا هو يواسي المنتخب
الفرنسي انا عندي رايي الخاص في اللقطه لا
نستطيع بعض
سوري اسف في التعبير بيحاول يحصل على لقطه
لرفع شعبيته من خلال كره القدم
[موسيقى]
البطيخ هو ده اللي بتكلم عنه يعني مهما
كنت عايش في مجتمع ليبرا وكذا يجب عليك ان
تحترم رمز الدوله وليس الشخص حتى لا اعرف
يعني يعني عبر عن حزنك
واحترم من جاء لوسيك بطريقه افضل من ذلك
شكرا